foreign
[Music]
maybe if you open yourself up to it
there's a possibility I don't think so
Quinn
quell
I don't think so well what I'm trying to
say Peter you know this is an open line
right what we're listening to everything
you're saying and it is painful and
you're just telling me now we were
hoping I would stop on its own but I
switched it over to private what color
button did you push blue for the blue
suit oh no blue was the Open Line for
everyone orange is for blue what black
is for orange yellow is for green green
is for red and red is for yellow no
yellow is for yellow green is for red
red is for green I don't think so try it
though
hello
you're right
Drax stay here with rocket watch him
that's who they're coming for I want to
come no mantis watch Drax group
you know what to do with these
foreign
looks like you're pushing the keyhole
the what there's a button under the
handle press that in
okay now what open the door
that is a stupid design and your
instructions were very unclear
what did you go bro
[Music]
on the ground
when sire moves us to the new world
gonna need names
I mean
eight nine two one two it's not really a
name
so
I would like my name to be
Lila
that's a pretty name Lila
thank you
I think my name shall be Thieves
because although we all do have them
mine are definitely the most prominent
thieves thiefs Lila tips
maybe called floor because me is lying
on floor you're lying on a floor so your
name is floor yeah
what about you friend
Someday I'm gonna make great machines
that fly
and me and my friends are gonna go
flying together
into the forever and beautiful sky
Lila
teeths and floor
and me
rocket
rocket it really is good to have friends
yeah
I'm so sorry about this Yoda oh please
we're here to save the life of our
friend that is all
we paid her to help us get in and get
out you think that'd mean oh I'm gonna
help you do it in a way that no one
knows it's happening but no what she
means is I'm gonna shoot people threaten
people's lives
and I know you're probably asking why
would I trust her well that's a good
question
the answer is
we used to be in love yeah she was my
girlfriend only she doesn't remember it
because it wasn't her because her dad
threw off a magic clip and she died and
then I lost my temper and nearly
destroyed half the universe
and she came back out of the past there
she is everyone else who died in the
past stay dead not her why was it the
magic Cliff I don't know that's some
freaking infinity stone scientist
some dumbass Earth dude who met a girl
fell in love
that girl died and then came back a
total dick
you left out some important information
but
that is the gist of it
your friend once took advantage
I learned my lessons
I aimed some small parts of my mental
capacity back in my own Direction and
now gravity itself serves my whims you
must find counter Earth familiar counter
Earth I visited your planet many years
ago Earth hasn't been my planet in a
long time your people had
wonderful spirit the art and music and
literature with some of the finest in
the universe
Earth would be a fabulous place for it
not for the ignorance and bigotry okay
it inspired me to create counter-ups I
don't care all of the good and none of
the bad I don't need another speech by
some impotent whack job whose mother
didn't love him rationalizing why he
needs to conquer the universe I'm not
trying to conquer the universe
I'm perfecting it
let me tell you something
I formed the Guardians
[Music]
[Applause]
that girl died but then she came back
came back a total dick oh please he left
out some important information but
that is the gist of it
my sacred mission
is to create the perfect Society
perfect
[Music]
I want you all to know that I'm grateful
to find beside my friends
incinerate them
we're always searching for a family
until we found each other
are you ready
for One Last Ride
away together
into the forever
and beautiful sky
[Applause]
whoever it was that you were in love
with it sounds more like her hers do not
bring me into them
knock it out what
notice how black your eyes were they
were replaced by my father as a method
of torture he he picked a pretty set
what's up everybody Chris Pratt here
they've given me a camera and a list of
rules all of which I'm going to ignore
to be reunited with this Guardians
family for volume three it's really
fantastic we're genuine fans so there's
something really sweet about geeking out
on set
you had me at hello
the Guardians is about humor it's about
action it's about Cosmic Adventures
Drax sit up that's what it's here for
tracks it's called a sofa it's not a bed
what find it hard to breathe it doesn't
have multiple purposes
but it's really about this found family
don't forget where we came from this is
a rocket origin story we are learning
more and more about what rocket has been
through
we're always searching for a family and
how we found each other
let's give the Galaxy something to
remember us by
it's so beautiful
everything is in the detail it's
imagination Music Beautiful imagery it's
really a fantastic story from the brain
of a Mad genius James Gunn
everything that drives it is that
emotional Center of all of these
characters who are all Outsiders we have
been running our whole lives Pete I'm
done running
hello everybody I'm so proud of what
we've accomplished I want you all to
know that I'm grateful to find this side
my friends
it's another rock opera it's really
fantastic and it wraps it up in a way
that really only James could are you
ready
for One Last Ride
Willow fly away together into the
forever
and beautiful sky
foreign
the camera for this movie because if I
did it would look terrible
[Music]